as an essential business nevada state
bank has continued to serve the
financial needs of its clients
throughout the challenges of copenhagen
and they're now being recognized
for those services here's more on that
nevada state bank is special for many
reasons as a colleague of the bank
we are very focused on creating an
engaging work environment
we even have a team a colleague
engagement team
that conducts events and activities for
our colleagues
we want them to know that we want them
to have a full employee experience it's
not just about serving our clients which
is of course so important but they could
do that at any other bank
we want them to have opportunities to
develop themselves so we were
top 10 in the forbes best in state
employer award which was really exciting
and then also we received third place
for large companies in the top
workplaces nevada award
as well as receiving the values award
the values award was extremely important
to us because the core values of the
bank
are the absolute pillar upon which we do
business and upon which our colleagues
choose to be employed with us and so
those core that values award was
really touching for us so nevada state
bank has eight core values and they are
accountability adaptability community
communication extraordinary service
development
teamwork and respect
we also recently our entire executive
management committee
went out to almost every branch across
the state to check in on our branch
colleagues who have been serving our
clients
daily since this pandemic began and we
wanted to tell them
thank you for everything you've done and
so you know every single branch was
visited almost um entirely and it was
such a great experience because we were
showing them directly that appreciation
we also allow our colleagues to give
back to the community and that is so
important
we all live in our communities in which
we work and so we allow our colleagues
to go and volunteer in the community
nevada state bank has several
upcoming events one that's coming really
soon is november 1st and that's our
virtual jdrf one walk
terry shirey our president and ceo is
the chairman of that walk this year
we're really excited for that event
our branches have been raising dollars
and they're going to be virtually
walking miles to support that effort
on november 5th and 6th we will be
collecting food
through a drive-through to benefit the
las vegas rescue mission so that's a
canned food drive
that will meet our social distancing
needs but also support that effort
and then in december we'll be supporting
the kluc
toy drive for help of southern nevada
and we participate in that
for many years for any additional
information about these events you can
follow our social media
so our facebook twitter instagram pages
and then also check into
uh one of the branches when you're doing
your business there we'll have bins in
the branches for our kuc toy drive and
you can also make other donations for
our other events while you're in the
branch
[Music]
we want to thank nevada state bank for
being one of our community pride
partners